hello everyone and welcome to round 13
of the 2018 candidates tournament with a
game between Fabiano Khurana and Levin
Aragon now I don't have any photos of
this game unfortunately because the game
ended rather quickly only four hours not
the usual six or seven hours so Niki
probably didn't have the chance to
upload them but let's just remember here
are the final standings after round 12
we have kurakin in first place and carry
on sharing in first place with seven
seven points and Iranian with four
points in is in last place so this game
doesn't really have that much meaning to
211 other other than maybe he maybe he
doesn't want to lose rating points
anymore but it definitely could mean the
difference between winning the
candidates and not winning the canvas
the Fabiano Caruana so let's see this
game Fabi opens with E 4 we have E 5 and
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
b5 so the rule opus a6 more fees defense
Bishop to a4 Knight to f6 castles Bishop
to e7 rook to e1 and b5 all standard
theory and Bishop to b3 castles now b3
b6 this is still all already seen like a
lot of times
Bishop to d2 and now Bishop to g4 c3 d5
and now we have h3 attacking the bishop
bishop to h5 and Queen to e2 rook to b8
Bishop to g5 and now D captures on e4
captures on e4 and now h6 but should be
back to c1 Bishop to g6 and now Knight B
to d2 and you'll see not be too deep you
okay
guarding d4 pawn and the bishop on g6 it
seems like a very active piece but
you'll see later in the game of how much
trouble we'll xi have for having this
Bishop on g6 night to h5 now preparing
to jump to f4
would would the knight first knife to f1
IRA maneuvering Bishop to c5 and now g3
not allowing the knight to come to f4
king - h7 simply improving as the
spawn can never move since there's a
bishop on v3 so first came to each age
seven improving the position also f5
will be an idea in the future and Fabian
also improves keep the g2 as the bishop
is slicing all the way here and maybe in
the future in night captures and g3
would be an idea now it wasn't at the
moment because there's a knight an f1
but you know better improve it
immediately Queen to e7 and the bishop
to c2 now we have rook to the 8th and b4
we have Bishop to b6 now comes a four
and Knight to f6 and here knife to h4
and now you can see how weird the
position of this bishop on g6 is it
can't really go anywhere
this night will capture it at one point
then black will have to ruin his pawn
structure it's unlikely you will want to
capture with the King and e6 so Queen to
e6 and first before capturing on g6
although capturing on g6 immediately is
definitely an idea 11 doesn't really
have a lot in this position he wants to
play Queen to c4 and maybe exchange
Queens here but first before capturing
the bishop Fabiano improves the position
Bishop to d3 he doesn't allow the Queen
to come to to come to c4 also now be
captors and a4 doesn't really work that
well because the bishop will also be
eyeing the a6 pawn and here at 11 plays
it better to h5 he avoids this trade for
a bishop for a night with the idea this
is basically one big bluff
everyone's Fabiano to move his queen and
if he moves his Queen then then the
lemons position would definitely be okay
but here if I beyond of course his bluff
and he plays g4 and this was lemons idea
he plays Bishop captures on g4 h
captures on g4 and Knight captures on g4
so it is a it is a peace sacrifice
although he did grab to piece two points
for the piece so it's it's not that
that's severe Knight to f5 now this is
definitely the best move
blocking the Queen from from entering
the position near the white king and
preparing some preparing some ideas
Knight captures on f2 this was well
and I'm grabbing 1/3 pound for the piece
but here comes the problem Bishop the c2
first moving the bishop as both the
knight and the roof were attacking the
bishop on d3 and now g6 attacking fob is
night on f5 and now if you if you play a
move like Knight back to e3 okay now we
block the bishop there definitely is a
threat of Queen captures a knife - but
now black has this nice to h3 move the
knight is well protected by the Queen
and there's the threat of nice - a4
white wood white wouldn't really have a
lot of fun here so after this g6 move
Bobby plays Knight 1 - III he
temporarily gives up a piece but he will
win the DF two nights so it's not a big
deal
G captures on f5 we have he captures on
f5 and now the the only move for black
which Levin finds it Queen to f6 and the
Queen to f6 is is a start of a an
interesting variation but you'll see
what I mean by this Queen captures on f2
was played so Bobby is still up a piece
now and here xi played efore he played
efore with the idea of opening up here
the attack to the c3 pawn by the Queen
but more importantly of making the room
on e5 for this night so Knight will come
to e5 and the bishop is nice nicely
placed and b6 and this rock is coming to
g8 but this move is actually a mistake
as you'll see in the game the correct
way to play this was actually Knight
captures on before and now if you don't
capture the night then sorry if you
don't capture the night the night is
coming to d3 we're gonna tack on the
rook on the Queen White will have to
capture it black will recapture with the
rook and then put the other book on the
D file and by having doubled rooks under
on the D file Aragon would definitely
have plenty of compensation for the
piece but if you of course captured
Knight would see capture some before
then you get rook to d4 now the rook is
nicely controlling this square here this
other rook is now coming to g8 and now
this would this would be definitely okay
for
but you have to find this deform move
Ariane didn't find this so after Queen
captures on f2 he played efore but now
this doesn't work here Fabi plays rook
to h1 Bishop captures on e4 is the best
move it's the engine stop choice but
that's just the engine showing off that
it can grab a pawn and still continue
playing this game Fabi doesn't need to
show off he just wants to he just wants
to win this game rook to h1 was played
now rook to d6 preparing to bring more
defenders to the h6 pawn and only now
Fabi plays the Bishop captures on e4
unnie for as now there's time rook to g8
check King to f1 and now comes nice to
e5 and it seems like black really does
have a lot of pieces surrounding the
black king the white king but Queen to a
4 or 5 is Fabi plays the strongest move
and now what do you do here you don't
really you don't really have a good move
here for black in the game c6 was played
by Oregon which is indeed the engine
stop choice so you can't complain about
him making a move like c6 but here
instead of here rook captures and h6 is
a forced win with the idea that after
rook captures on h6 Queen captures on h6
now you have f6 check a discover check
from the bishop for now if you move the
king of course you can move it to g7
that pawn is blocking at the point is
covering the g7 square so if you move
the king simply Queen captures Queen
will be checkmate we can just see that
this is a very nice checkmate
so after f6 you would have to block it
rook to g6 and now comes Queen captures
on h6 you have to capture with the King
the rook is pinned in captures and now
Knight to c4 check
not-not-not Knight to f5 check which
seems like it's basically the same thing
you're gonna pick up the rook but it's
not after King to h5 and now you have to
recapture it you get rook captures on f6
with check and now we're gonna pick up
the knight on d6 so Knight would have to
block and now you have King to g4 and
now you're gonna win two pieces for a
rook so after white makes a move simply
captures captures captures and
you would have three points against four
points and what would we have in the
exchange but you know what would have a
very hard time winning this so basically
after this scheme captures on h6 you
play nice to see four check now open up
a discover check from the bishop here
and now it's winning King moves and now
because the King is on a light square
simply Bishop captures on g6 this is
wood check King captors and now you
captured rook on d6 and now you are up a
whole rook easily winning the game so
after the c6 by Aragon rook captures on
h6 was definitely winning I'm pretty
sure Fabi should have seen this but
first he played a capture some b5
seemingly improving the position instead
of playing and playing the finishing
blow
but maybe this is now just Fabi showing
off he's maybe saying my position is so
well that it doesn't matter if I can
even capture a pawn on the other side
I'm the other side of the board where
nothing is happening there's still
nothing you can do here so rook to g5
not even caring about the pawn arlynn
tries to improve his position maybe take
something here that that maybe Fabi
missed like the rook h6 idea but here
Fabi plays pawn captures on a6 so
grabbing another pawn and now creating a
beautiful passed pawn here on the Queen
side so not only does he have a better
position now he has a past a sex pawn on
the Queen side here Queen to d8 was
played by Levin and here comes f6 check
what do you do here Knight to g6
blocking and now finally if I we played
rook captures on h6 and it was in this
position that xi Arnon resigned at the
game what if you resign well obviously
if you capture the rook then you get
Queen 2h to check Roe cast the block
rogue aged five and now comes Knight to
g4 and now you have to this is a double
check from the bishop and the night you
have to move the King Queen captures and
after King moves Bishop captures on g6
this is this is completely winning you
don't have to calculate a couple of
checks for example Ruby one Kingi to now
Rob g1 King h2 but now after Queen to c7
you have
simply going to e5 blocking check and
white is simply winning here rope
capture screen captures and Bishop
captures with check king h3 rook check
King h4 and it's all over white is up a
piece and up two points and heavens
fabulous have a pest a sick spawn on the
Queen side so no no point in even trying
something here and another thing is
after this rook captures on h6 you don't
really have the option of declining this
if you for example move King to g8 then
you get Queen captures on g5 rook
captures on f6 but you don't really have
anything to play here okay maybe maybe
rope captures on f6 would check but you
simply move the king and there's really
no move here black can make he is down a
whole rook and okay it seems like there
is this rook to f1 check kind of
checking the king and winning the Queen
and g5 but unfortunately after Knight
captures on f1 the bishop is guarding
the Queen so nothing nothing happening
there white is again simply crushing
this position so after rook captures on
h6
ahran and resigned the game and now Fabi
I don't know about all the standings
because not all of the games have
finished a kremlings game against the
king is still going on but I did I did
see that Cara can drew his game against
Wesley so rather quickly so now it's
actually Fabiano who is in the lead
again half a point
half a point ahead of ahead of kurakin
and I will show one more game the one
I'm a media versus Greece Chuck so by
then probably the chronicling game will
will will be finished and I will also
show you the final standings and the
pairings for the final rounds tomorrow
so yeah that's the game a tough game 411
Ariane a brilliant game by Fabi you know
what a way to come back after after
losing that game against Kuryakin and
yeah I mean not the greatest tournament
for 411 and yesterday I think I think a
soil today that he actually dropped
below
the world's top 10 chess players in the
live ratings list but that's to be
expected he like lost all of the games
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual we can check two of
my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
another game from the candidates like I
said the the Madeira crystal game and
hopefully with some nice photos from
Mickey I thank you all and I will see
you soon